hello everyone i'm dr emilia javorsky
from the future of life institute where
at the institute i lead up our efforts
on lethal autonomous weapons and i am
super thrilled to be here today to speak
with this amazing group of people uh who
hail from very different backgrounds and
perspectives but something they all
should have in common is a great
dedication and work on working to
safeguard our world from the from lethal
autonomous weapons and so we're coming
together today because we're really at a
pivotal moment in this issue it for the
world to decide what our future will
look like with autonomous weapons which
we define
as weapons that use ai to select and
apply force against targets like human
beings without human intervention
and over the next few weeks the un is
slated to meet in geneva
at something called the convention on
certain conventional weapons to debate
this issue to debate what should the
world do about the threat of autonomous
weapons and at the heart of that
question is the determination that this
is the moment where the global community
is going to make the decision
are we going to allow ai to decide who
lives and who dies
and because of this urgency and because
of this
the magnitude of the issue that we're
dealing with at the future of life
institute we are releasing a short film
that is really a follow-up to a film we
released back in 2017 called
slaughterbots when we released that
first film that was really a film aimed
to
raise awareness about the issue of
lethal autonomous weapons and sort of
put it on the map now three short years
later sort of since we've
released that film we're living in a
world in which we're already seeing
media reports across the globe of small
companies producing these types of
weapons and them being used on the
battlefield and so we decided to create
another short film to both follow up in
warning people of that risk but also
depicting what is the kind of thinking
that's happening right now that's
driving us towards that end point and
more importantly what is it that we can
do about it and what can the world do
about it given this really important
moment that we have with this un meeting
to perhaps steer ourselves in another
direction
so
that was why we put that film
together but the panel today is to kind
of from the realm of storytelling into
the realm of reality and hearing these
different perspectives on the state of
lethal autonomous weapons and also what
are our policy options for moving
forward
and so with that i would like to bring
together on on stage our our great panel
um and i would like each person to sort
of kick this off by introducing
themselves and telling us a little bit
about who you are
what organization you're with and and
your perspective on this issue so i will
start off with max
it's an honor to be here i'm
max tegmark yeah i'm a professor at mit
where i work on a little bit of physics
but mostly ai research for the past five
years and i'm also one of the founders
of the future of life institute
because i love technology and i believe
that artificial intelligence in
particular
has the potential
to be the most awesome technology ever
helping life flourish like never before
but it also has the potential
to be the worst thing ever to happen to
humanity and i think
this issue of lethal thomas weapons is
really really the first fork in the road
where we have to make the right decision
because
the key to a
wonderful future where ai
helps us cure diseases and
helps live let's live healthy and
wealthy and
inspiring lives or is
to draw a clear red line between all of
these wonderful uses
and the small
set of really really terrible uses which
would ruin everything and if we can't
even agree
that we don't want to use ai
to anonymously kill people and to decide
entirely on its own who lives and who
dies now who are we kidding
that we're ever going to be able to draw
any kind of lines
just be our ai towards towards
the good future that we all want
awesome thank you max stuart
uh so i'm stuart russell i'm a professor
of computer science at the university of
california berkeley
um i've been doing artificial
intelligence there for
more than 35 years
and
i'm also director of the center for
human compatible artificial intelligence
uh and like max i am very concerned that
ai be beneficial
uh for the human race in future and i
share his optimism that it can be
enormously beneficial
um
i've been
concerned about autonomous weapons since
around 2013
uh initially as a member of human rights
watch which
participates in the campaign to stop
killer robots
but also as an expert testifying at the
united nations
i've come to believe that
pushing forward with autonomous weapons
would be disastrous for
international security
and even domestic security
wonderful richard
hi emilia hi everybody i'm richard moyes
from article 36 which is an ngo based in
the uk we also coordinate the stock
killer robots campaign which is a
partnership of non-governmental
organizations more than 180
organizations i think now who are
concerned with this issue who are
pushing for states to develop an
international legal treaty on this issue
i suppose my background is is really in
the world of weapons i i worked for like
my clearance organizations in the past
and then i've been working in the world
of weapons policy and law so really
coming at it not from the ai side but
from the side of thinking as a society
about well frankly how we're allowed to
kill each other in in these
international in these international
settings and recognizing i think max
used the term drawing lines recognizing
that when it comes to how we we kill
each other how we engage in that you
know very
primitive practice in a way but there's
a social recognition that we need to
draw some lines we need to draw some
boundaries about the role of technology
in that and when we start to look at
autonomy and weapon system i think we
also see the need for the clear lines to
be drawn in this area to sort of step
expectations in society that frankly
killing people is always going to be
problematic but giving machines the
power to kill people is just is just
crossing a line that that's unacceptable
to us so we're working as a partnership
to secure a legal outcome on this issue
maya
so my name is maya briem i'm a legal
advisor at the international committee
of the red cross or in short icrc
um
the icrc's exclusively humanitarian
mission is to protect the lives and the
dignity of persons affected by armed
conflict war
and other situations of violence and the
icc acts to preserve people's lives and
livelihoods and provides assistance to
them to people in need
and we also seek to prevent suffering by
promoting and strengthening
international humanitarian law george
ihl that's the law applicable to war
and broader universal humanitarian
principles and so
part of the icrc's work since its
inception is to
support states in the development of
international humanitarian law including
to prohibit or regulate certain weapons
based on a realistic assessment of their
adverse humanitarian impacts
so
in the past the icrc's
the src has played an important role for
example in the processes that led to
treaties prohibiting anti-personnel
landmines or the treaty prohibiting
clustuminations
and
in more recent years the icrc has given
focused attention to emerging
technologies of warfare so new forms of
waiting war
new weapons enabled by developments in
science and technology including of
course
autonomous weapon systems
wonderful
thank you all so much for being here
today i can already tell in sort of our
opening statements um there's a lot of
differences in sort of our perspectives
of concern but i already sense that
everyone has some degree of optimism
that something can be done on this which
is is a good place to start
um so i'm really excited to sort of dig
into the content here on autonomous
weapon systems you know from from my
perspective i'm a physician by training
and i came to this issue in thinking
about how we think through the use of ai
and life and death decisions in a very
different context which is in the
context of saving lives and in that
thinking our professional association
the medic american medical association
developed a policy in which they don't
even recognize artificial intelligence
they say when it comes to life and death
decisions it's called augmented
intelligence because there's an
irreplaceable role of a human being and
human judgment when it comes to thinking
through decisions that affect a human
being's health and well-being and so it
always struck me that it was totally
absurd that on this parallel
conversation we're having about
hey let's use ai to kill people without
humans in the loop right this strikes
for me a really deep moral moral problem
right and that there is a fundamental
moral issue here with allowing
algorithms to make the decision over who
lives and who dies and so the moral
dimension is is certainly i think one
but i'd be interested to know from each
of your different perspectives how do
you think through what are the problems
with lethal autonomous weapon systems
why why are they so bad and why are we
all here sort of dedicating our time to
do something about them so i'll kick
that off with stuart um because i know
you've been thinking through different
dimensions of this for quite some time
thanks amelia yeah i think um the moral
dimension is very important and
um i know that some very significant
figures including the secretary general
of the united nations
uh believe that the the moral aspect is
in fact decisive that these are morally
unacceptable weapons
um
even if i share that view and i think i
do
um i don't think it's going to be
persuasive to governments who don't
trust
the moral
behavior of other governments because
even though the moral governments might
refrain from using such weapons
they're not going to trust the the other
governments
to do the same and so they're not going
to uh to agree to a treaty on that basis
um
when i think about autonomous weapons to
me the main characteristic that they
have that's different from other weapons
we have some pretty horrible weapons
that are so-called allowed already um
the main difference is that they don't
require a human being
to be there supervising or pulling the
trigger or
launching the missile
and if you know anything about computer
science
what we know is if a computer can do
something once it can do it a million
times or a billion times
they're very very good at doing the same
thing over and over again in vast
quantities we call this scalability in
computer science and it's a it's seen as
an asset for computers because it it
lets them do lots of tedious
calculations uh without a human having
to uh insert themselves in every single
one of those calculations but when it
comes to killing that means that
you can launch a million or 10 million
weapons
simultaneously you know from a small
control center
and wipe out entire human populations
you can do it selectively so you could
wipe out you know all males of military
age for example you could wipe out
all persons visibly belonging to a
reduced
religious group or an ethnic group
and um
do we want to be part of this kind of
weapon it would seem to me that uh
they would replace nuclear weapons in
almost all
of the roles that people have for
nuclear weapons
um because they're cheaper they're
easier to build
they don't leave behind a radioactive
crater
they leave all the physical assets
intact
and we don't sell nuclear weapons in
supermarkets for a good reason
it's not a moral reason
it's a practical reason
and if we allow these kinds of weapons
to go ahead it will be just as if we
were selling nuclear weapons in the
supermarket
so democratized weapons of mass
destruction sound deeply concerning for
to me at least uh max is the other sort
of technologist on the panel what what
are your reactions to what stewart said
yeah i'd like to follow up on the
supermarket comment that stuart made
there because i think
the biggest misconception that we see in
a lot of governments
and even in the united nations i think
is that this is primarily a military
issue
when it's actually primarily a civilian
issue and i was so happy to hear from
you maya you know how the icrc cares
about humanitarian
issues more broadly than just military
ones
last year for example
many people think that most people who
were killed by weapons last year were
killed in
wars or other armed conflicts that's not
true
most people who were killed by weapons
last year were not killed in syria
afghanistan iraq or yemen they were
killed in mexico
why
crime primarily
and it would be incredibly naive to
think
that if you had these slaughter bots
things as
cheap and small as a smartphone
available in supermarkets or more likely
any arms black market right at the same
price as a kalashnikov rifle
that these would that we wouldn't see
exactly the same use cases there just
just like most people
in the past were killed by weapons in
civilian context
they will even the future too but now
with these weapons instead that's the
primary use case and do we really want
to live in a future where
anyone
who for whatever reason wants to kill
anybody anonymously can do so
for a very affordable price and not even
get caught
that would be the end of
open society as we know it and it's a
much much bigger issue i think than um
than military issues
thank you max and i guess i would add to
what you both you and stuart have said
about the ubiquity of these and sort of
this idea of them being
available in supermarkets is the other
side of this is they may not necessarily
even be produced by the same military
producers that we think of right at
least from what we've seen so far on the
trajectory of autonomous weapons is a
lot of the people looking into making
these can be sort of small private
companies because exactly as you say
these are not terribly expensive or or
sort of difficult to make
richard how do you think through the
problems that these systems raise are
they similar or different concerns that
you have
yeah i mean i think this this is an
issue where you can bring together and
justifiably there are a wide range of
different problem framings as i would
describe them and i think in my mind i
tend to work out with from the sort of
narrower to the to the wider i feel like
at a more at the most fundamental level
where i see a sort of moral set of moral
anxieties is in any of these machine
systems you know you're using sensors
and you know computers to analyze sensor
data
inevitably you know machines don't see
people they don't see humans as humans
they they're categorizing the world into
certain
pre-programmed classification structures
they're applying labels to things based
within certain rigid structures and if
we're applying labels to things through
machines and then labeling them to be
subject to the application of force
there's a reduction in that process of
the reality of human existence into
simply a pattern of data to be to be
processed in a in a mechanical way
effectively so in that process of
functioning i think when it comes to
machines targeting people say there is
immediately a degree of
sort of reduction and a loss of our
humanity in that in that sort of process
i think that's there fundamentally but i
think it just gets worse if you know in
students examples if you start to
imagine how either deliberately or
inadvertently because of the biases in
inherent in certain data sets you start
to identify as enemies
people of particular skin colors or
petite people of particular uh genders
and and the like i mean the way we start
to formalize
these these processes of prejudice in
the world and and tie them into the
application of force i think there's
there's all sorts of concerns in that
space so again drawing a line against
systems that would target people i think
is a is a fundamental moral moral
response and then there's more practical
sort of pragmatic concerns that
you start to lose control i mean we
civil society have framed our concerns
on this issue often in terms of the need
to retain meaningful human control i
think there is a
sort of
tendency for a natural rejection of the
idea of machines making decisions about
killing but the the point at which a
decision shifts from being a human
making a decision to a machine making
decision isn't entirely straightforward
there's a there's a sort of uh there's a
scaling of understanding and perhaps uh
human um contextual knowledge that goes
on in these situations so so
that's another area of concern that we
start to see essentially an erosion of
of our expectations for what people know
when they use force if it starts to
become reasonable for people to simply
to put their faith in machines and and
actually have no real understanding of
the contextual implications of that that
also produces major problems both
practically for for who gets killed harm
to civilians is a significant concern
but also then these potentially
unintended
uh scaling of effects which uh i think
where you start to get security concerns
you know is it possible that
incidents occur uh inadvertently and
they start to escalate through these
interconnected systems into wider
societal concerns so i think there's a
range of moral and practical they have
legal implications i guess the icrc can
speak well to
that
and i think
wider than all of this there's these
wider questions which max alluded to
about our relationship with technology
and society our relationship with these
automated decision makings and
decision-making systems in other areas
of our lives if we can't draw lines
against this what does it mean for how
we as people are going to relate to
technology in in the in the broad sense
and how are we going to actually control
our own future in relation to technology
so there's a lot of implicat issues
implicated in this subject matter which
i think also means it will demand the
response thanks
excellent richard yeah i think you've
hit on some really great ones there that
you know this idea of sort of digital
dehumanization i know is something you
guys have talked about a lot and this
idea of reducing our humanity to a
sensor input um is something that is is
deeply
frightening and disconcerting you also
mentioned the legal and maya do you want
to jump in here on how the icrc thinks
through some of these issues and why you
guys have sort of engaged on this topic
in particular
sure
um well first of all i should say that i
i mean we totally see this the these
sorts of risks and concerns as others
have mentioned security concerns
concerns for peace non-proliferation
conflict escalation and so on
um i also take this opportunity perhaps
to
um
to say a little bit how the icc views or
understands autonomous weapons which is
slightly different from some of the
presentations that uh that we've already
heard so
for us what really sets autonomous
weapons apart from other weapons is that
they select and apply force to targets
without human intervention in the sense
that
after their initial activation by a
human being
the system self initiates force
application it is it is triggered in
response to information from its result
environment received through sensors and
on the basis of a generalized target
profile
and so in our review this
manner of functioning is already a
reality today so this is not only this
is not a future only concern and
for example um
mines and sense of used weapons function
in this way certain so-called loitering
munitions or active protection systems
and certain missile and rocket defense
systems
and of course this way your functioning
could be applied to a wide variety of
other weapons and munitions and so these
can be relatively technically
rudimentary or complex and in our view
they need not rely on artificial
intelligence or machine learning
techniques but they may and they
probably increasingly uh will
so
with that
said what
what autonomous weapons then from this
perspective have in common is that
um the user does not choose
and may not even know the specific
target the concrete target that triggers
a strike and therefore doesn't know the
precise timing or location of the
resulting force application and this
loss of human control and judgment in
the use of force
brings with it
fundamental ethical concerns that
richard has already
mentioned in effect
substituting human decisions about life
and death with sensors software and
machine processes
and
and of course it also brings particular
challenges
for users of the weapons in terms of
being able to anticipate and limit the
effects of autonomous weapons use
and that
of course carries a risk for those
affected by armed conflict notably
civilians but also soldiers or the gomba
wounded soldiers for example
and with it challenges for compliance
with the rules of international
humanitarian law notably the rules that
govern the conduct of hostilities
so for example there is a risk that an
autonomous weapon that is intended
to
strike military personnel carriers
be triggered by a civilian car
and there is also a risk that civilians
and civilian objects may be harmed due
to an autonomous weapon striking in
their vicinity
so since autonomous weapon users
do not choose the particular target and
time and location the specific time and
location of force application
a critical question from a humanitarian
perspective and from the perspective of
compliance with the law is
under what conditions may uses of
autonomous weapons be reasonably certain
that an attack is not directed against
civilians and civilian objects
and that all feasible precautions uh are
taken to avoid and minimize harm to
civilians because
uh civilians must be protected against
the effects of hostility civilians must
not be targeted
in war and um as
so these these these uh legal rules they
demand
context-specific value judgments that uh
do not lend themselves to being encoded
in software processes and this
specificity context dependency of legal
assessment poses a major challenge to
the legal use of autonomous weapons from
our perspective
really insightful maya that was that was
really helpful i think something that
you just mentioned too is that you know
there's a certain urgency around the
thinking of this that it's it's not
necessarily science fiction that we're
talking about we're talking about
technology that exists today in a
technological capability that exists
today and we think about this um a lot
when you you sort of hear what stewart
was saying earlier about applying the
principles of tech to
autonomous weapon systems because they
are fundamentally a problem of
technology and when we think about that
we think about that sort of exponential
curve at which technology proliferates
right you think about when you look at
cell phone use right and how many people
have a cell phone it's a nice it starts
out slow and then that log curve goes up
pretty quickly um and given these use
reports that we've started to see
trickle in what we've been seeing in
terms of increasing rates of companies
getting in to develop these types of
systems something that keeps me up at
night is a worry that we are on the cusp
of going up on that linear part of the
curve which is why i see this as a very
urgent issue
max how do you think through the urgency
of of this topic
it's it's quite striking that when we
made the slaughterbots film
just a few years ago a lot of people
were like ah forget it this is science
fiction you know decades away and sadly
now they're already here
we
all know
what we read in the united nations
report recently about how they were used
to hunt down
fleeing people in libya last year for
example and
we have uh this um
absurd situation where where there's
this
aren't this
full this unregulated arms market where
small companies from turkey and other
countries
are just cashing in a lot of profits
from from
producing and selling these things to
whoever they want
completely legally
and
i think politicians are largely asleep
at the wheel here thinking that they
have time to drink coffee and
discuss this for years and years and
years
that's not the time scale in which this
sort of technology works
and
you know
either we put we stop this arm's release
now before it gets totally out of
control or
we can
basically forget about that as this open
society that that that we know and love
and as as stewart
often likes to point out you know the
current position of
powerful nation states like the the us
and great britain for instance
is
completely absurd they they say on one
hand yes you know these are going to be
decisive in the battle space
and no we are not going to build full
autonomous weapons ourselves but we
insist
on the right for everybody else
including some of the random turkish
companies that you never heard of
to mass produce these and sell them to
absolutely whoever
they want
makes absolutely no sense and
that's why we very very quickly need to
get to the point where there is so much
stigma around these disgusting weapons
that um
nobody makes them
so stuart since your name was invoked
here
how close are we getting to buying these
things in the supermarket
and um to max's point as well
what's your thinking you mentioned
international security earlier is this
actually in the best interest of
countries like the us and great britain
the countries that we think of as major
military powers
so as max said the the technology is
already there um you know slaughterbots
uh the film came out in november of
2017.
the cargo drone which is the one that
was used in libya last year uh was
announced three weeks later
so while the russian ambassador was
scoffing that slaughterbots wouldn't
exist for another 25 years so why are we
even discussing this um
the turkish company stm had already been
developing this product uh presumably
for several years by that point and
announced it three weeks later
um
and
you know this this point about the
the diplomatic positions of the us and
the uk
um being absurd when i
went to the white house the ai community
sent a delegation
of senior researchers to the white house
and we talked to
uh senior members of the national
security council defense department
state department
and we described this possibility
of you know anti-personnel weapons
being scaled up and used as weapons of
mass destruction their response was well
but we would never develop weapons like
that
and our response was well in that case
why don't you agree to ban them
um i mean it just seems absurd to say
well you know we the civilized
governments of the world have such high
moral standards that we would never ever
uh develop and use autonomous weapons on
on an anti-personnel scale
um
but then if that if that's true
then you should agree to ban them um so
uh i think one possible conclusion is
it's not true
um that they are intending to develop
them another argument that they made at
the same meeting was
um that you know perhaps
uh you know the the civilized
governments the major powers
uh would develop these weapons but they
would never fall into the wrong hands
they would never proliferate uh we're
very very good at keeping control of all
our weapons um you know so
we pointed out that the united states
simply lost 200 000
uh automatic weapons in iraq uh they
have no idea where they went uh and we
have a pretty good idea where they went
not to mention afghanistan and
afghanistan and so on you know there's a
hundred million kalashnikovs in private
hands
so so that argument is obviously
complete nonsense um and then well what
was the first use of the cargo of the
cargo weapon it was in libya where
there's a strict u.n embargo on all arms
sales
and it was used by one of the
the non-state active factions in the
conflict
um and it was used to attack forces who
are running away right so so
it was already a you know violation of
international humanitarian law because
uh it's not militarily necessary to
attack troops who are already running
away uh and it was used in violation of
a u.n embargo
and it was used by non-state actors so
uh all the arguments i think um that you
know that we know what we're doing you
know where the grown-ups we're going to
keep control over all this stuff uh i
just think they're completely specious
yeah i think those are great points you
make uh stuart about the rapid
proliferation risk especially of these
smaller embodiment weapons that are more
of the anti-personnel type right that
aren't really that different than an
ak-47 uh at
at the end of the day in terms of
likelihood of sort of cost to
manufacture and complexity i think
richard
actually i mean
land mines uh
can go as little as six dollars each
yeah um so it's really you know it's
actually a smaller explosive a lot
smaller explosive than a landmine um
uh
the the quadcopter part if you want to
make a little quadcopter uh you can buy
for a couple of dollars um and then
you've got a tiny little cheap camera uh
and and a chip so i think
uh 25 if if you manufacture these in
very large numbers
totally
richard on the civil society side you
guys have been calling for a while for
urgent action on this can can you take
us through how you see urgency either
similarly or differently than maxim
stewart
yeah i mean i think um
i think we do see
more
use
more emphasis on these technologies in
practice i mean there's been
examples here in relation to certain
what they're you know called loitering
munitions but we see this perhaps
expansion of existing
technologies and
potentially greater greater use of that
so
in those contexts
we don't necessarily have transparency
or detailed understandings of actually
how those systems are functioning in
practice or what rules are being applied
in their use so uh at the very least it
feels clear that we need clarification
of how do people understand the law in
relation to
these these systems in practice so
yes there's a there's a there's a
momentum from
in the from the sort of military
technology side
i also think there's a kind of there's a
normative urgency to this i mean
particularly on the anti-personnel
side actually in society
antibiotic landmines were used very
widely
and a lot of people were killed and
injured and impoverished as a result of
that so we
we undertook the what as a society
globally we undertook the widespread use
of a particular set of technologies that
use sensors to target people and frankly
it was a humanitarian disaster and the
large majority of states have decided to
consider anti-personnel mines illegal as
a result some states haven't but the
great majority have
now there hasn't actually been as yet a
widespread adoption of other systems
that use
sensors and algorithms to target people
i think that means we have an
opportunity now it you know
prohibiting systems before they uh come
to fruition that has its own challenges
this sort of uh
navigating negotiating the boundaries
for the future you know presents
difficulties but i think it's a better
challenge to be faced with than trying
to claw back technologies once they've
already uh become once they've already
proliferated and once more importantly
they've become acceptable in some way
because there's a danger that that uh
states then have an incentive to to
claim the acceptability of certain
technologies so yeah i think there's an
urgency because we have the opportunity
to draw some lines
now which if we don't draw them lat now
will be more difficult to
to create and to pull back towards in
the in the future so i think it's a it's
an opportunity uh it's an opportunity
for us
completely returning into that point as
well the idea that
how easy it is to claw something back
right it's if it's a fighter jet that
goes wrong well that's a lot easier to
claw back than something that's small
and cheap and and has proliferated
widely
uh maya on from your perspective i think
the word urgent does appear in the
icrc's recommendations to the rep cons
how how do you guys think through this
topic
sure we've um we've in fact called since
2015 on states to agree international
limits on autonomous weapons um
so that the urgency is certainly here
i'd also like to sort of reflect a
little bit on what others have said um
it's
important i think to keep in mind that
developments in this area developments
on uh the kinds of technologies that are
developed the kinds of weapon
technologies that are developed are the
result of of choices they are not
pre-determined so resistance is not
futile and i would agree with uh with
richard that we do have an opportunity
here and we are actually in a fairly
sort of um
a good place in the sense that we have a
deep and wide-ranging debate on on on
this issue uh already so um i think we
should should keep that sort of this mo
this this this sense of of urgency but
also the sense of opportunity um at the
forefront of our minds when we're
discussing autonomous weapons
um
the
for us what what is uh remarkable is
that in
pres so as i said we understand
autonomous weapons in a way that
includes certain existing weapon systems
and in present-day military practice the
the use of these these autonomous
weapons is tends to be strictly limited
in ways that can help reduce
humanitarian risks and that can
facilitate uh compliance with
international humanitarian law so
for example an autonomous air defense
system
these tend to be used only to target
typical military objects in this case
incoming missiles or military aircraft
and in in this case but also other
existing autonomous weapons i think it
is significant that the
allegations of use of autonomous weapons
to directly target people they are
emphatically refuted by
alleged
users i think this is significant
because it speaks to one of those moral
lines that others have evoked as well is
that in present military practice
autonomous weapons are not used to
target persons directly with the
exception of anti-personnel landmines
which have been outlawed by treaty to
which a majority of states has signed up
to now
in existing practice autonomous weapons
also tend to be used only for
limited time time frames limited
duration in well-defined geographical
zones
and in situations where civilians and
civilian objects such as civilian
aircraft for instance are are not
present so um could be around a military
base where civilian aircraft are
excluded from entering the the air space
and they tend to be used under constant
human supervision and with the ability
for the users to intervene and to
deactivate the system where necessary
now
all of this uh we think speaks to
also not only practical limits but also
sort of normative limits things that
should remain in place even as
technology allows um
different uses and what we are uh
concerned about is that certain trends
in military interests and investments
that aim at uh that that aim at using
autonomous weapons increasingly also to
target persons directly um as well as a
wider range of objects such as uh
vehicles as i said vehicles may also be
used by civilians depending on on the
target profile right
use in increasingly populated areas even
in the midst of cities
over larger
spaces longer periods and at much larger
scale i think stuart has has spoken to
this so there are these um
ideas of of the deploying entire swarms
and then of course with much reduced
human supervision and increasingly
relying on artificial intelligence and
machine learning techniques
and
considering the speed at which these
developments are taking place
we really believe it is urgent that
states agree an effective international
response to the to the ethical
humanitarian and legal and security
risks um that we see on the horizon
awesome and i think that's also a great
point you make too in grounding this
conversation is that we're not talking
about
putting limits on all applications of ai
and all types of weaponry there's many
uses of ai you know we think of things
like missile defense systems that don't
have the same types of raise the same
set of concerns and considerations as
using ai and anti-personnel systems
right um
can you maybe let's maybe switch gears
here now into the
all right so we have this problem we
know it's urgent
what is it that we can do about it and
what are policy frameworks that may be
helpful for this and maybe you know i
know there's
especially for max and stewart's
thinking having been in this for a while
what what may be other unhelpful
suggestions that may be out there so my
will you take us through how does the
icc think about what what should the
world do what is the policy response
that you guys would like to see happen
sure yeah so actually earlier this year
in may the icrc offered a set of more
specific recommendations to all states
with a view to supporting state's
current efforts at establishing
international limits on autonomous
weapons and with view to ensuring
civilian protection in war compliance
with international humanitarian law and
also ethical acceptability so concretely
the icrc recommends that states adopt
new legally binding rules
in in particular certain prohibitions
and restrictions and so
one
type of autonomous weapons that we
recommend that states prohibit are what
we call unpredictable autonomous weapons
these are autonomous weapons that are
designed or used in a manner such that
their effects cannot sufficiently be
understood predicted and explained
and this is of course
a concern that for us is particularly
acute with
autonomous weapons that continue to
learn
targets during use yeah that would be
one example that for us we we find
extremely risky and would like to see
prohibited
second in light of uh ethical
considerations to safeguard humanity and
and also to uphold respect for
international humanitarian law
we recommend that autonomous weapons
that are designed or used to target
persons directly should be prohibited
and uh as we've already many of us have
said this is uh grounded in in a deep
ethical uh objections to this sort of
sort of killing right life death
decisions basically devolved to to
machine processes and it also grounded
in concern particularly at acute
concerns that international humanitarian
law may be violated
in the targeting of persons
via
on the basis of target profiles right
because the user um
is not
selecting a particular person and
therefore is not in a position to
reasonably assess whether that person at
that moment may be targeted
now um
also with the view to the protection of
civilians and uh to safeguard humanity
the icc also recommends that the design
and use of all non-prohibited autonomous
weapons
should be strictly regulated through a
combination of limits and requirements
notably limits on the types of targets
such as constraining them to objects
that are typical military objects so
typically that are legally speaking
military objectives by nature such as
enemy weapons or or enemy tanks
limits on the duration geographical
scope and the scale of autonomous weapon
use and that is aimed in particular to
enable the users
to
remain
aware of the circumstances of an attack
enough to actually
to
for human judgment and control to be
sufficient and meaningful in every
specific attack
as well as limits on the situations of
use such as constraining autonomous
weapons to situations where civilians
and civilian objects are not present and
that um is of course in particular
because of the the risks to civilians
if they are in the vicinity of
targets that may trigger an autonomous
weapon strike and this risk is of course
particularly acute
where civilians are
present in high density such as in the
midst of of cities
and then finally requirements for human
machine interaction notably to ensure
effective human supervision and timely
intervention and deactivation when this
becomes necessary
so these are the sorts of
recommendations that we that we
that we put out and um
uh
welcome uh reactions from states and
uh uh continue to work towards to
support states in in in this direction
excellent
thank you maya as we close in these last
few minutes of the panel um richard from
the civil society side of things how
does maya's policy prescription sound to
you
yeah i mean i think we're also pushing
for a legal instrument and i think it we
think it needs to be one that contains
prohibitions
it's gonna ban systems that can't be
used with meaningful human control it's
gonna ban systems that would target
people and it needs to have these other
rules positive obligations to to keep
control over the use of systems because
i think as we've already discussed on
this panel we have weapons today that
work using sensors in this way and we
need to stop a sort of slippage of those
systems into into an unacceptable future
so the combination of prohibitions and
positive obligations to to retain
meaningful human control and to prevent
this sort of digital dehumanization a
couple of things just to add
it's it's states it's governments who
have to create international law so
in terms of what needs to be done we
need to push governments to
to speak in favor of these of these
these responses to to push themselves
for a legal treaty in response to this
to this issue and
to be honest over recent years these
these issues have been under discussion
in the convention on conventional
weapons you mentioned it at the
beginning
it's not a forum that frankly
is
very likely to lead to an outcome even
though the majority of states now
internationally who are engaged in these
discussions the majority of states i
think support a movement to to begin
negotiations so
i think that before too long there will
be frustration with this pattern of
talks and i think there'll be a movement
amongst those states who who do want to
make progress on this issue to start to
develop a legal instrument uh more on
their own terms directly working towards
this kind of this kind of outcome and
that leads me really to my to my final
um point which is you know an
international treaty isn't an end in
itself an international treaty is an
instrument that's got to fulfill certain
purposes it's got to shape
the normative landscape that we're
working in which really means the sort
of social expectations what does good
behavior look like what does bad
behavior unacceptable behavior look like
and we need a legal instrument that that
sets out that landscape in a particular
direction that our ex sets our
expectations of governments and also
flowing down from that sets our
expectations for the tech sector for
commercial companies for for arms
manufacturers sets the expectations of
where they need to impose limits on
their own practices
because ultimately i think we all
socially have a have a stake in drawing
these enjoying these lines we need to
create a social landscape amongst
ourselves we have to have belief in
norms and in laws and in social
standards we have to have a belief that
that we can constrain you know
technology in this respect so ultimately
it's about
feeling empowered we need people to feel
empowered that we can draw the lines in
this in this space and to be honest i
feel pretty confident we've done it
before on other weapons issues as a
society we've found ways to draw lines
and they have
saved thousands and thousands of lives
frankly so i think we should have
confidence that we can do the same on
this issue
amazing stuart i know you need to leave
shortly what what are your thoughts on
this topic i know you've been dealing
with these diplomatic discussions for
quite some time
uh
yeah so
i think the first thing i would like is
that the
the various nations who are discussing
this
um
actually have a clear understanding of
what it is that they're talking about um
so for example at the moment there's a
proposal
to ban
what what they call fully autonomous
weapons and what that means is weapons
that operate completely outside the
framework of any human control
and what that means is weapons that wake
up in the morning
and decide by themselves that they're
going to start a war with another
country right in other words what they
would ban is the conscious
self-aware skynet that that controls all
the terminator robots in other words
they they would ban something that
doesn't exist
probably will never exist uh leaving all
other actual weapons that anyone would
actually develop uh legal so that's the
first problem
uh we've got to get away from this
nonsense that we're worried about
machines becoming conscious and deciding
to go around shooting people that is a
complete uh fiction
the other issue is i'm very concerned
about any
treaty that restricts use but not
restricting weapons
i think the oh the history shows us that
the only practical way to do this is to
ban classes of weapons we saw this with
chemical weapons before the first world
war they were banned
but
not as a class of weapons what was
banned was the use
of chemical weapons you were allowed to
develop them you were allowed to deploy
them but you couldn't use them
and of course along comes world war one
everyone has these big stockpiles and
guess what they got used and so
you don't want to create that slippery
slope
by allowing the development of these
weapons and then saying oh but we're
only going to use them in these very
restricted contexts right because those
very restricted contexts you know as
soon as real conflict happens you know
those uh those rules are going to go out
the window um you have to have ways of
targeting
um the manufacturing of weapons on a
large scale
and i don't think
uh
we can afford to
to let that go ahead
because once it goes ahead uh as max
said
life as we know it will change forever
thank you stuart and i know that you
have to leave so i'll also give you a
moment here to say any last words that
you'd like to say on on this issue
i would like to say
uh
last words to it
my
last words
uh
you know i i share richard's optimism um
that
we have been able to do this in the past
the bands that we have put in place on
chemical and biological weapons have
been
largely successful
and in fact it was the biologists who
pointed out
that
creating effective biological weapons
would reduce the security of every
nation
rather than increasing the security of
the nations who were producing them
and the same goes for
the development of autonomous weapons so
i think the bioweapons example is
actually a great one because when we
think about the biological weapons
convention that's been a very powerful
treaty in terms of its efficacy over the
years and one that hasn't really have
the same type of verification regime
that we associate with something like
the chemical weapons treaty and what
that treaty did it's a great example of
safeguarding a science right in that
case biology and by taking the
weaponization of biology off of the
table it not only mitigated the risks of
bioweapons but it also allowed biology
to really flourish as a field and to
grow and for us to think of biotech as
something that's great and positive and
cures diseases and gives us new
medicines so one could imagine here that
there could be a similar future for
artificial intelligence where if we sort
of take the weaponizing of ai and ai
deciding to kill people off of the table
it helps to open the doors for the
science to really flourish and sort of
reach all of its potential
max i know this is something you think
about a lot in terms of the positive
potential of ai do you agree with the
others in terms of what should be done
about this issue and how do you think
through action on this topic
in terms of
the optimism there on what we can learn
from biology i completely agree with you
in terms of what should we be done
maybe this is my opportunity to maybe
annoy the rest of you on the panel by
saying something controversial
i am increasingly convinced that we
actually need two treaties
not one
artificial intelligence is
such a general-purpose technology that
having one treaty for weapons that
contain a.i
is
becoming as ridiculous as having a
treaty for all weapons that involve
motors
or explosives you know and if you
instead
ask what sort of division of weapon
types makes sense
it's really very clear that on one hand
there are the big and heavy expensive
weapons that are used against tanks
airplanes ships and so on
they need to be big because you need a
lot of power to blow through a tank or
shoot down an airplane
and on the other hand you have the
weapons that the icrc
wants to ban
which target humans specifically the
reason they can be so tiny
and small and cheap is because we humans
are not heavily armored
right and those are precisely the
weapons that
because of their
low price and low mass you can become
weapons of mass destruction where
where very few can kill very many i
think we should have completely separate
treaties for the two of them i think for
the first kind the big expensive ones
the ccw
might be a reasonable form for this
because of course it was as was
mentioned already
unpredictable weapons that are
intrinsically destabilizing and maybe
will cause the us and china to
accidentally get into a nuclear war with
each other that's not in china's
interest or in the us's interest and
that can give the superpowers an
incentive to go to ccw and
and agree on various
norms and rules
for the military aspects here for the
for the big heavy expensive weapons the
other stuff
doesn't belong in the ccw at all right
the ccw is about
a forum for discussing military weapons
it has the word conventional in the name
there's nothing conventional about
weapons of mass destruction where one
dude can kill 100 000 people by pressing
a button and unleashing a slaughterbot
swarm and as we already discussed right
the main victims here the main use cases
are civilian
not military
so i would like to see
in parallel with the ccw new forum focus
specifically on weapons that target
humans from not a military perspective
but from a humanitarian perspective
saying this is a disaster for
civilization as we know it
it'll cause the mother of all tech
clashes against the ai field and also
thereby rob us of all the great benefits
we could get from it
and let these two
processes play out in parallel
not
wait
for years and years and years while the
ccw discusses military things
to have
all these civilian things get out of
control in the meantime
let's see if i
annoyed anyone but i really think this
makes sense
annoyance is good um but i think well
we've heard a lot of different
perspectives here on the what we should
do about it there is some
fundamentals that go across all of the
thinking which is this idea of needing
to draw a line and needing to prohibit
certain types of weapons and needing to
do that in a form factor that is a
legally binding treaty and it's not some
sort of political promise or anything
sort of
more measly than that something that
really is new law around these these
threats that we face
i really sort of want to just take this
moment as we come to a close here um to
thank everyone it's been so awesome
talking with all of you and we'll just
do one more round of passing the mic
here i know all of us choose and care
deeply about this issue that we dedicate
years of our time to this
um and thinking through this so
you know
any last thoughts that you have or
perspectives that you want to share maya
i'll start with you
thanks amelia um yeah perhaps just to
come back to this moment of opportunity
that we have here there's a real
momentum in the
discussions on autonomous weapons
systems that are underway the positions
of states are becoming increasingly
nuanced and sophisticated and with that
they also discover areas of agreement
where before they were
aware of that
um i also think just reflecting a little
bit on what um on what maxwell said um
this issue like um many others that will
be on the horizon i think in the in the
future um has the potential for enormous
complexity but for political action is
sometimes necessary to
focus on some fundamentals elementary
things
so rather than
getting too too uh distracted by the
very the various forms that autonomous
weapons can take uh we would recommend
taking uh sort of a what we like to call
a more technology agnostic approach and
approach that focuses on the human
within this
use of force
process and really aims at preserving
and maintaining
sufficient human judgment and control
and that
norms
around this we can articulate them and
we can formalize them in the form of of
internationally legally binding norms
without having all the specificities all
the information about uh what what what
autonomous weapons will look like in the
future what they can and cannot do and
so on and so
for
for
more generally i would say that
discussions in the ccw and and wider
discussions on and various applications
of developments in science and
technology i think they really benefit
from diverse people contributing to them
and
contributing in particular to
to debates deliberations on the
acceptability and the desirability of
new weapons and of course technologists
philosophers
social scientists and other
knowledgeable people
really all have a stake in this because
ultimately this is about our common
humanity about the rules um that protect
us all in in case in case of war and so
it's really critical to foster these
sorts of uh dialogues among different
communities of practice and the wider
public and the future of life institute
is doing a great job at
at supporting at at enabling these sorts
of of discussions so thank you very much
for that
thank you maya so well said and we so
deeply respect the work that you do and
the icrc does and i'm so thrilled to
have you with us today so we we greatly
appreciate it as well
richard you're you're kind of closing
thoughts
yeah thanks amelia and perhaps picking
up on some of the themes
there i mean the
stock killer robots campaign is a
partnership of
you know hundreds of organizations
people working together coming from
different backgrounds concerned with
this issue
i've worked on the development of a
number of international legal
instruments on and political instruments
on weapons and all of those processes
have relied ultimately on a partnership
of states along with international
organizations like the icrc un agencies
and un officials and then civil society
and the wider uh social community of
stakeholders and i think that's going to
be the key to to making progress on
on this issue
like meyer i would i would pay tribute
to the work that fli has done
particularly bringing the voices of
technologists and scientists into this
you know so strongly into this debate
because those voices are you know
fundamentally important in this issue of
our relationship to to technology in
in society
i think we have these partnerships
building up now this is basically back
to grounds for optimism i think we have
a majority of states who are engaged in
the discussion speaking up in favor of
the need for negotiations
they may not be able to bring that to
full fruition through the
through the ccw but
we have as a as a basic foundation a
majority of states recognizing that this
issue needs uh needs negotiations
we have an agreement more and more
around a policy orientation that
contains prohibitions and and
regulations prohibitions and
restrictions and i think
whilst there's areas of divergence
within that a recognition that this is
about keeping human control in the use
of force and avoiding a sort of
dehumanization
both of the people that you know would
be killed but also perhaps of ourselves
as you know if we're complicit in that
in that process so i think we have this
greater and greater policy coherence
building partnership of states
civil society and international
organizations and a wider community
paying attention to the issue
i think that negotiations of a treaty
will will begin on this in the next few
years the exact route to that is uh is
you know something we're working on but
i feel very confident based on past
experience that that is going to come
about i can't guarantee it'll be two
treaties max may be raising the raising
the bar a little bit uh here but i think
we can get one treaty that responds
directly to our concerns and that
challenges states to
to come to the table and to sign up to
it and to set some standards in society
how we keep you know keep our humanity
in the face of these technological
changes
thanks
thank you richard and to avoid being a
gratitude fest but i will go there is
thank you for your leadership on this
and also as you've said you know with
with the campaign it's something that's
reflective in the
composed of hundreds of organizations
around the world that have been working
tirelessly to advance the types of
thinking on this issue and the policy
proposals that we have today so also
taking a moment to recognize how many
different organizations and people are
working so hard every day to to get us
towards that goal to get us towards that
treaty
max
let's see if i can inject some more
optimism here at the end by zooming out
a little bit to the bigger picture so
you know here we are 13.8 billion years
after our big bang
sitting on this little spinning ball in
space
looking out and just into this amazing
cosmos that we've only become aware of
the vastness of it pretty recently
now why is it that 2021
is a much nicer year to live in than
5000 years ago when the life expectancy
was 30.
everything we love about civilization is
the product of technology
and that's why i love
thinking about technology and and
working
on technology right
but it's important to not take
technology as our new religion and have
this mantra oh you know more technology
is automatically going to be good
because technology is not morally good
it's also not evil it's just a tool that
we can use to do good or bad things and
the key
to get to
where we are have gotten so far and the
key to an inspiring future is really to
make sure that it is we
humans who control the technology
not the technology that controls us
and several of you pointed out that
there's
no more ridiculous example of the latter
than if you let the technology on its
own
go out and decide you know who gets
killed and who lives
but more broadly
for the optimism part you know the
this is a much more fun and inspiring
discussion
the business about what to do with ai
technology than it is to talk about
nuclear weapons
where you're just
the two options are either we destroy
each other in a nuclear war or nothing
happens there's no upside
here there's an enormous upside because
our civilization has been built with
human intelligence if we can amplify
this intelligence with artificial
intelligence
suddenly we're not going to be
stumped by all these things we're
stumped by now
we will only be limited by the laws of
physics
we can create an
almost unbelievably inspiring future
where we
figure out how to cure all the diseases
that are placed in pledging playing us
today we can stabilize our climate we
can enable people to flirt life to
flourish
people living healthy meaningful
prosperous lives not just for the next
election cycle maybe for billions of
years maybe not even only on earth but
throughout much of this amazing cosmos
you know
it's this amazing upside
that really really makes it so important
to ban lethal autonomous weapons the
point is not to avoid bad things the
point is to
draw that line and
avoid doing these this tiny fraction of
stupid things that would derail us
and make a squander this otherwise
amazing opportunity that we have and the
more we can focus on the upside this
truly inspiring future that we want to
live in
the more likely it is that we will live
in that future
thank you max and i think something that
you that you said there that really
resonates with me is the power of ai
right we're going to go in one direction
or another it's not going to be some
sort of mediocre future that we have
with artificial intelligence it's either
going to be one that is that beautiful
positive flourishing vision or it's a
it's a pretty dark one right and the
ability to steer which direction we go
in lies in our hands today and i think
that's why
we're so optimistic is the fact that we
see that vision we see that vision of ai
transforming the world for the better
and and we feel a responsibility to do
what we can to steer towards that and by
doing that steer away from some of these
bad outcomes and as you say it
it's important that human control is is
front and center at that process and
that as we develop these powerful
technologies we deploy them and develop
them with wisdom right and wisdom on
some of these early use cases and i
think that is at the core what we're
talking about with this whole panel
today which is lethal autonomous weapons
are a very early decision we need to
make about our control of ai and
steering it in a which direction it
shall go in towards the future
and we have this opportunity now to to
hopefully get it right so
with that i will thank all of the
panelists for being here today for
sharing your perspectives and looking
forward to continuing the journey with
all of you towards towards a treaty
towards getting that decision right um
and just i'm so thankful that all of you
are here today
thank you thank you all wonderful
[Music]